welcome to my most sadistic creation
the tangled nightmare of extension cords
that lives
in our supply closet your mission is to
untangle
your lamp's cord plug it in and then poo
yourself to it on your dolly and turn it
on oh nice hitchcock's coming down from
the speed
i have a chance freaks begin
[Music]
what is that grab the top one and get
the bottom one oh my god that's what you
meant
although i'm open to whatever you want
to try here we go diaz i want to
apologize
i'm not talking to you oh oh amy it
worked the packing worked what no
here we go oh
gotcha you're never going to catch me oh
yeah
yeah yes i did it and hitchhike's going
to lose
rosa and holtz are going to beat him
rosa stop i give up
i want you to know i'm sorry for prying
win this thing and enjoy your day off
and if you ever want a friend to sit
with you and silently listen to death
metal
just know i'm always here
okay i'd like that
what no what are you freaks doing we're
leaving the competition
some things are more important than a
game no they're not
wait where are you going don't leave we
need you oh
why does the ceiling hate me
i don't get it why did you make this bet
in the first place i don't know
terry kept saying all that stuff about
how i matured and i got worried i was
becoming a boring adult
you are not a boring adult no i
am you want to know why i really wanted
that year of no paperwork
and so if we did get pregnant i would
have more time to help with the baby
oh i'll save your ah i don't deserve it
i'm just some boring responsible guy
that's about to
lose our car you're still pretty
irresponsible
you're just saying that cause you're my
wife no i'm not
yesterday you took the batteries out of
our smoke detector to put in your big
mouth billy bass you noticed
yeah in a bad way yeah
now get up and win this bet you can do
this
yeah you're right i can do this yeah
yeah i maybe can't do this the time has
come for the grand finale
the obstacle course this is gonna be
rough turns out taking a ton of random
pills is
really bad for you everything hurts yeah
i'm like 50 50 gonna die
on your mark get set dazzle me freaks
first you must make your way past the
barricade hurdles
after the hurdles you must fish a dollar
coin out of our gross clog
up sink of nightmares
you'll use that money to buy a hot dog
after you eat the entire dog
you'll return to the break room where
you must extract an olive from the
windpipe of a heimlich practice tummy
why are you using your mouth for
everything the winner will be the first
person to sit in the ring master's
throne
oh surprise twist to get to the throne
you must break through a breach training
door what why are you making this so
hard on me it's all for the show
jake the greatest show on earth all
right fine i can do this
for my wife
yeah it didn't work my skeleton feels
like it's made of skin also i can't do
it amy yes you can
okay you just need a little energy and
debbie's epipens are full of adrenaline
is that a smart thing to do
probably not but sometimes it's good to
be a little irresponsible that could
make me sick
it's better than losing our car i mean
is it cause
[Applause]
i will never die
[Music]
jake is champion congratulations you
inherit the circus
i did it i don't want the circus
you